[Music]
that's right folks spiderman is in fact
peter parker are you spiderman's
girlfriend
are you spiderman's girlfriend
please don't touch her you're just a kid
well i'll tell you what i call him
public enemy number one
[Music]
dude
hello peter
hi
do i know you what have you done with my
machine
i don't know what you're talking about i
don't know what machine
do you want to play games
[Music]
don't worry ma'am i'm coming
[Music]
you ready
i'm ready
nice knowing you spiderman excuse me
the entire world's about to forget that
peter parker is spider-man everyone
uh can't some people still know perhaps
not how the spell works so my
girlfriend's just gonna forget about
everything we've been through i mean is
she even gonna be my girlfriend all
right fine okay
everyone in the world is going to forget
that you're spider-man except your
girlfriend thank you so much that
oh my god nick okay let's not change the
parameters of this spell anymore while
i'm okay i'm done i'm done i swear i'm
done i'm done
now but my auntie
octavius
[Music]
osborne
what what happened to you what happened
to
you're the walking corpse
what do you mean you died
norman
years ago
you're insane god i love it here what
are you talking about
he's standing right there he's dead
they both died fighting spider-man
give me the box
[Music]
[Music]
what is this place the mirror dimension
where i'm in control strange stuff can
we please just talk about this parker
don't you realize that in the multiverse
there are an infinite number of people
who know peter parker is spider-man and
if that spell gets loose they're all
coming here look i know i get it but we
can't just send them home to die it's
their fate
you can't change that any more than you
can change who they are
oh what are you doing
[Music]
what's your name peter
you're gwen right quinn cece
i love you and you're always gonna be my
best you're gonna make enemies people
will get hurt
you don't give people hope you take it
away
i'm gonna take away yours
are you okay
yeah okay
are you okay
[Music]
stop arguing both of you peter one peter
two peter
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry
whatever
[Music]
[Music]
it is weird staring at you for that long
whoa
let's save me mj
you've been rolling this off
[Music]
just me
here buddy let me help you yes
it's okay should we do the kiss
excuse me
i think i can repair dylan and marco but
the others
the idea that they are all the same
thing and they could all come together
and sort of help each other that to me
felt like it was part of the dna of the
story that we were already trying to
tell
and that gave me an entry point to
actually get them together so that it
was a story element and an emotional
thing
they grow and they change and they
evolve from different writers different
artists in the case of the films
different actors that's why the marvel
characters have persevered so long
through decades
and then you have the fun of starting to
pitch it to the actors and doing
something that is worthy of their time
and of their energy and stepping back
into this role i had butterflies in
those meetings with kobe and andy hoping
that they would sign up this is peter
parker peter parker spider-man
spider-man there are other me's from
another dimension this is the wizard
that i was telling you about
with great power
comes great responsibility
keep being a friendly neighborhood
spider-man
that's what we do
guys what we do
all right let's do this
focus trust your tingle
i have the tingle thing just not for
brent
you are amazing thank you yeah will you
say it no i kind of needed to hear that
thank you
peter one
eight or two
you know three
i love you guys
we just had a little dance in the suit
yeah cuddle we had to cuddle the cobwebs
off a little bit for me
doing a photo shoot with
two lads in lycra
[Music]
[Music]
the suit can definitely be like a
challenge at times when you got to get
in the full thing um
but then like getting comfortable in it
there is something fun yeah it just
helps as an actor when you get in your
costume you begin to like feel it more
and embody it more and i'm still
processing it's all happening still i'm
catching up yeah this only just happened
but objectively you got pretty free
pretty quick oh yeah
that's true you started to feel pretty
at home
yeah pretty quickly i did yeah i just i
have no explanation for it it just did
instinctual yeah it releases something
it just did it
watching tom through this journey from
the first movie into now has been so
rewarding the first movie is about
spider-man really wanting to prove
himself to tony stark and working so
hard to do that that he ends up screwing
up and making things a million times
worse like that's just exactly how i
felt on the first movie tom and i both
felt the same like where are we what's
going on this is a crazy opportunity
let's not screw it up this is insane
look at this thing look we both grew up
together i don't feel like it was a
parental role i felt like we were all
the kids what's interesting in the
previous films is that he really has
been the spider boy what about me what
about you
i mean what if mrs stark needs me or
something or i don't know something that
goes down and this film is about him
becoming spider-man it's about him
growing up making his own decisions and
stepping up to the plate as a full-blown
avenger and it's been really nice to
kind of have that dovetail between
myself and spider-man homecoming and now
who i am and who peter parker is and
spider-man no way home my name is peter
parker
and i
would like a coffee
please
[Music]
we're going to lift you up on a cherry
picker and you're going to jump off
how they became super villains it's just
so funny i fell into a super collider
gotta be careful where you fall to work
with them is honestly the highlight of
my career me and toby arrived and all of
their arms were just open
[Music]
[Music]
red butterflies with toby and andrew
hoping they would sign up
[Music]
so
[Music]
you